welcome to your mom's house
you know what's really not cool is that
I have a jacket that I had tailored
because I was super fat when I deliver
after I delivered the kid and I got this
nice jacket and I had it tailored so
that I could look normal on stage and
then I came home from the comedy store
the other night and I was so happy to
wear it and I like debuted and it
happened you said oh you look like an
art teacher can we post a picture of you
in it it's on my Instagram it is me at
the Comedy Store I'm on stage wearing it
it's a black and white
I guess kind of like a houndstooth II
can you pull it up yeah I like I like
fucking broke you know I always look
really cute and then you told me I look
like a fucking high school art teacher
and piece of shit
it's right here this is it it's black
and white but it's a black and white
coat so it doesn't need to be shouting
can you look I mean blue man is that
really that is it really that bad I was
feeling pretty good about myself too I
came off feeling myself I was feeling
like Tamar I came back on autofocus on
top I came back from the store and I I
felt as good as tamer that's why okay
why are you yeah yeah yeah so what do
you think of the photo though our
teacher yeah yeah Thank You blue man you
can't really tell in this picture though
to be fair we should take another
picture fine we'll take another
photograph of my coat that I had
tailored to fit my fat postpartum body
to make me about myself say that and
then you know oh look it's you you're an
art teacher thanks huh babe what what
are you doing where are you going
through me is just too much going on
over here why are you going through my
Instagram account right now why can't I
go through it because it's my phone
give me my my phone you don't let me go
through yours give it to me how come you
know the codes to all my show don't know
any other cozier shit
what are you going through my searches
now just to see what's going on yeah you
don't need to see what's going on